we all know Chad Johnson has been the  breakout star so far on this season of  The Bachelorette  what's up dude welcome Here I am but  apparently the show's token villain  hadn't actually watched himself yet Chad  just instagrammed this video him  watching TV captioning it I finally  watched the show now I understand why  some people hate me haha but some parts  were hilarious - hey  gotta give Chad credit he might say some  pretty terrible stuff do you think I  can't find you you think I won't go out  of my way to come to your house I'm dead  serious  but he's owning it all the Bachelorette  was on hiatus this week but it's back  Monday June 20th and I will be watching  until then you can keep your Chad  cravings satisfied with all these  shirtless photos he posts of himself  you